البندقية هي مدينة كبيرة
كان من الجنون أن نبنيها هنا وهي
معجزة نجت من
هذه المدينة الرائعة
جدران القصور الرخامية للقناة التي تمنع
المد
[تصفيق]
ولا تزال تفاجئني عندما أتيت
إلى البندقية
أن الطرق عبارة عن ممرات مائية
هناك  هناك ثلاثة أشياء يقولها الناس دائمًا
عن البندقية ، الأول ولكن هناك عدد كبير جدًا
من السياح ، والثاني أنه
مكلف
للغاية والثالث
أنه يواجه أزمة وجودية ،
قد يكون كل هؤلاء الثلاثة صحيحًا ، ولكن
عندما أنظر إلى  وجهة النظر
هذه تختفي هذه الهواجس بدلاً من ذلك ، أرى
أعجوبة هندسية استمرت أكثر
من ألف عام
وبنية فريدة من نوعها مع الحمض النووي
الذي يجب أن نكتشف أن
هناك حقيقة بسيطة لا يمكن إنكارها حول
البندقية في
النهاية بطريقة أو بأخرى
ستحصل عليها  على شكل من أشكال نقل المياه ،
سواء كانت حافلة مائية أو تاكسي ، أوه نعم
بالطبع الجندول ،
هيا هذه نظرة رائعة عليها
يوم جميل ، أليس كذلك؟  إعادة الميل
إلى اليمين لا أريد أن
أقلقك ، حسنًا ، لقد
حصل ناردين على الحق في ارتداء
الخطوط الرسمية لعربة الجندول منذ أكثر
من 40 عامًا.
أنت تعلم أنه في دمي خرجت من
المدرسة ،
ولم أستطع إيقافها ، وكانت
عربات الجندول منذ
ما يقرب من ألف عام رمزًا
لمكانة التجار والنخب الأثرياء الذين
عاشوا في هذه القصور ،
يمكنني أن أرى في الأصل الجندول والجندول
كانت عربات الجندول هي الشكل الرئيسي
لوسائل النقل ، لكنك أصبحت من
عوامل الجذب السياحي الآن ، حسنًا ، انظر جيدًا أن
هذه ليست مجرد وظيفة هي أسلوب حياة
[موسيقى
] الجندول هو ملاح ماهر
تدرب لسنوات عليك ارتداء
قميص الجندول الذي لم أفعله ولكن
لن يمنعني ذلك من المحاولة بشكل جيد ، انتقلت
الأشياء المثالية من التذبذب إلى الأسوأ ،
تراجع سريعًا قليلاً ، نعم
[موسيقى
] كانت قريبة جدًا ، لقد فقدنا
الكاميرا تقريبًا ، ألم نفقده
تقريبًا في صف ريتشارد أنا '  أنا أحاول أن
أدفع معصميك نحو ذقنك لأعلى
وليس
في البندقية ، الجميع خبير في
كيفية تجديف الجندول ،
ما الذي
يحدث
هناك ، تذهب بشكل مثالي
[موسيقى]
كنت أعلم أنه سيكون أصعب مما
يبدو عليه  لم ندرك أن الاحتفاظ
بالركاز على هذا القليل من الخشب
سيكون صعبًا ،
نعم ، لقد اجتزت اختبار ريتشارد ، شكرًا
لك على
الجميع التوقف للانضمام إلى سبب كون
التجديف هو أول شيء تتعلمه
كطفل وهو مهم جدًا مثل اللغة الإنجليزية
الأشخاص الذين
يتناولون الشاي ، لا تشرب الشاي ،
فأنت تتناول الشاي
هي طقوس
سيأخذها هذا الرجل الإنجليزي كابتشينو
بدلاً من ذلك
يفهم دور الجندول
ومكانة الجندول في هذا
المجتمع ويتم فتح نافذة جديدة على
البندقية.  أعتقد أنني أدركت بشكل صحيح أنك
تعرف كم هي مدينة
والمياه ليس فقط منطقة
جذب سياحي ، إنها مدينة حقيقية في
المياه ،
تقريبًا آه البندقية تدور حول
القنوات وهي تتعلق بالجندول أليس
كذلك نحن على دراية بذلك  هذا جيد جدا على المستوى
الشخصي  لكن
معظمنا يمثل المدينة